this is Steven floats and drop beat dad
uh slate I feel like I'm at the
dentist's office is a shine white light
behind the conscience I'm so sick of
like the exposure just going like you
know super bright super dark and stuff
so I want to be a little bit controlled
here um and yeah sorry we've been away
apparently that dropped like a million
episodes on us so we're just trying to
catch up here and yeah we're doing these
two together because I mean they're I
don't think is a ton to talk about I
think it makes sense just a sort of a
Lapham together um first one was about
donuts and flying mmm second one's about
sour cream and dancing so it's I see a
theme food plus movement yes so that's
it right um
so pretty much a first episode Steven
finds out eat for hours
oh um finds out he can float he's very
slowly falling to the ground and they
try to figure out how to bring it down
like a bad dream
I'm going to use where it's just like
hey I mean I know you're talking about
where it's like you're up in the air
like you're trying to get away you're
trying to move but you can't kind of
thing I kind of you're to count like
swimming almost except like in the air I
know you're talking about um but he
wants to get to is fresh doughnut or as
they say in the show oh I do like that
though because doughnuts are the most
sensual of all the fried yeasty
doughnuts are amazing um yeah so a good
good doughnut should be like a sexual
tea yes I very much agree and definitely
creamy uh right down to there's a gooey
hole that you get anyway um so the less
said about chocolate though the better a
fudge filling just I don't know I don't
know where this is going but anyway so
uh so that's an episode then we have a
drop beat Dan which is pretty much
exactly what you think it's gonna be
it's except us with sour cream who I
never realize how funny that name is
until they just keep saying it over and
over it's like Oh sour cream what do you
know about I'm like that does sound
funny every time they say it uh he's you
he's got a French relative you know
creme fraiche you mean creme um freeze
so his dad real dad comes into town
because apparently onions dad is a
stepdad which is really fascinating I
would have guessed that if they really
look alike and they have the similar
like skin tone everything then similar
hair but it's like no stuff they
apparently uh so his dad comes back into
town does everything that the deadbeat
dad story goes through he thinks he's
gonna be there he thinks everything's
gonna be alright but it turns out you
know he's just trying to use them and he
figures it out at the end sends in the
way and then just this huge bombshell
that there's suddenly millionaires
apparently so yeah that'll be internal I
like them i I don't know I mean well
we'll see where they go this maybe it's
not real maybe it was like a fake ours
about what it'd be a weird it's like
early in the morning and I'm still
drinking my coffee so I haven't woken up
quite a but I I feel like that's what
those things are I like blinked for a
sec was I wake did I just see them yeah
like if they're like there I hope they
don't know you're out cuz that's when
the show went downhill is when Roseanne
won the lottery and they became
billionaires um but yes the first
episode I like you says kind of
dreamlike and I like that it's one of
those where it's like okay he has his
cool power and this is kind of a flop
episode it's just her showing okay now
he has this ability it's once again tied
to his emotions which is done oh it
would just done all the time but I it's
it's a good cliche in my opinion you see
like in akhira I'm frozen it's not
everywhere but I'm trying like I'm
trying to remember it's their reason
they didn't try to just pull him down no
they try they tried weighing him down
but the weight would okay I guess that
just seems like overkill when I never
saw them once just try to grab him by
the legs and just nobody get that the
force won't move and force is not gonna
whether be polar pushy I'm just saying
it would have made more sense before
dropping a fucking boat to just try to
pull him down by the legs bottom line it
didn't work um so once again Stipe it
was emotions
done to death uh and if it was done in a
lesser show or in a
anyway I'd be like oh come on it's like
a this but they think you should do it
well Hiba makes the joke it's like just
like all of my powers for God's sake um
and I'll say one funny thing my wife
before she went to work she was watching
a little bit of it at the line where
he's trying to think of happy emotions
he says Mommy goes and those emotions
are complicated and she goes and says
why is that complicated because she
doesn't want to show them just like it's
complicated I tried is really gonna have
to trust us yeah I tried explaining it I
don't think I did a good job if you just
are like oh I will say this the one
thing I remember is uh the only time
Ronaldo tried to do something useful
pouring their guac soda over the chips
yeah I'm like all right that actually
made sense I love the idea of a guac
soda I think that is very funny uh
cuacamole is sort of like the new red
velvet it's like we always kind of go in
these shifts or so it's like any pumpkin
very small for their trends yeah there
was a light trip yeah there's kind of
clear stuff for a while like what
Christine that's eesh yeah then there
was a cookie dough that was everywhere
and then like red velvet everywhere and
yeah cupcakes now it's um guacamole um
seems the tunes the chocolate teenies
the appletini yeah all the teeny yeah so
um uh yes I thought that was very funny
but everything else with the episode
while it's fine uh I just felt like it
didn't bring anything that noon or to a
character that you really cared that
much about I me was anyone like I don't
know sour cream story well what's going
on with him you know kind of thing um
but I mean it's it's fine I mean these
stories of the deadbeat dad seem to be
more and more common um and I always
feel like somebody like whoever's with
oh the dad hate hair no I know I was
gonna say I get the feeling that the
people that write these episodes you
know either went through something like
that or know somebody that did something
it's just I really want to stick it to
that asshole I'm gonna write it around
this asshole and make him kind of look
like the villain and stuff like that
which I'm he took your brother's just
playing Debbie deserts deadbeat mom
tzer's that beat everybody uh buzz
deadbeats a lot of dead blood and it
beats but yeah I do kind of feel like
this sort of story's done a lot where
they think it's
to work and then they go back to their
old ways it's like no I should just cut
it off um my favorite line was 80% of
Germans have a career in DJing uh those
musicians no I thought he's a decent
Germans that maybe it's really my mom
maybe I was gonna say Germans I don't
even like if that's a joke it's like I'm
surreal but that was Germans vain' man
oh now we're gonna everyone's gonna go
back be like what was that joke it makes
sense of his musicians Germans doesn't
make sense but I kind of uninsurance did
makes doesn't that they're TJ's I don't
know well when I that apply a German
industrial music and like you know the
nightclub scene Oh have you ever been to
Berlin but where why are you talking
about Germans I don't know I totally
like Oz is now early in the morning I
know sure we're high though this is what
I know like me in the morning is like
just be being high I just have no idea
where I am and I was gonna say because
we both get up I mean right you get up
earlier than me to drop your wife about
him yet I was gone I was up before the
Sun came up
yeah I mean I usually get up like 6 or 7
you know something like that uh you know
I'm just more but I also have not had
coffee today which is a huge problem and
I can tell you that right now it's a
huge sigh over there I know I was
waiting for it to cool down the second
this camera shuts off I will drink it so
why don't you just cut the effing camera
up so I can get my goddamn coffee okay
um so um coffee is good we've learned
that yes um the last thing I'll say
about the two episodes because the guys
I think they're both fine I like the
falling one a little bit more and the
reason I like it a little bit more is
not always a dream like I love the shot
the shots of the clouds and this and I
love the angles they get wet ease up in
the air particularly early on it's a
very it's still a very pretty show yeah
I like it when a show or movie or
anything can legitimately capture being
in the air and they can do it very
simply uh you know Miyazaki is very good
at that you see that like in Kiki's
Delivery Service and stuff you really
feel like you're in the air
and I'm Louisville in the kitchen when
he was fuckin chef how cool I knew you
were good I don't think of the spirited
away what you know and those clouds are
very strange clouds cuz they're sort of
these sound lines for this or these
little brushes like almost like these
array strokes they're in there and so
how do you make that kind of
three-dimensional you know and layered
and stuff they do a good job but I
thought they actually made them look
very nice and very cool um sorry work
being good at what you do where I know I
guess I was in how did they do that I
was like oh it's pretty
no I mean it's because those clouds are
so strangely designed they're not all so
often not all are there's just these
very very many paintings how did they do
that well you could take a brush and
some paint in do you know you say that
but you're a child it's tough yes I've
actually tried painting them not
everybody's Bob Ross and hey that man it
was the da Vinci of his time and he's on
Netflix I still like you better than
Thomas Kincade any don't fuck with um
not only Thomas Kinkade sound like it's
got a nice but I don't know if I'm doing
his art word that I'm sorry the master
of life yeah maybe it's the hype maybe
it's the fact that he quote unquote
earned this you know I don't either boy
see I just saw this real but master I'm
wonderful I see Bob Watson seem full of
himself
no he's my Greek I know what I want an
excuse to get high and get other people
to meditate by just painting whatever
and he was pretty decent yeah and yeah
he was very much like you know whatever
you want to do I don't think he self
proclaimed himself anything but I get
really hot topic so you want to do if
you want to paint your own happy little
picture with a woman undressing that
you're spying on her then you can do
that people did so many parodies of that
and they're mostly very funny
oh but yeah so that's the two episodes I
know you wants to get these other ones
because everyone's like have you seen
the newest episodes like this shit goes
down so uh hopefully we'll get to even
more shit going down outside them
becoming billionaires I hope that goes
okay
I mean it's people see me talking
positive about it so hopefully it's good
that I mean I always feel like that's
usually not the best idea
but we'll see you know that the show has
done a lot of good stuff so I maybe
think I'm done stuff I'm getting doggone
he's gonna come yes coffee I'm a jar by
dropping it some Chilean his coffee it's
good yes
you